the current's already taking me I can
feel it
so I'll just let it do its thing
not far down the channel we spot
something
look at that
the fish trap so that's obviously the
michikenda
send it from tribes whose ancient
ancestors migrated out of the Great Rift
Valley the mijikenda people are found
all along this Coast
expert fishermen and sailors their
knowledge of this Coastline will be key
the time to make it all the way south to
the coral cave back colony
they're using this mangrove
as a place to fish
the michikinda set traps to take
advantage of fish brought in through the
tides
so they have a trap
or high tide
and a trap for low tide
seeing these
means I'm close
I should be running into people once I
get to
get to the coast
until then I've got to avoid getting
trapped by any snags beneath the surface
ride the current
down
towards the ocean
[Music]
okay
holy committal now
thank you
I have made it through the mangroves
but with the current showing no sign of
slowing down
I now risk being dragged dangerously far
out I'm getting got stepped into the
ocean
[Music]
the current is too strong to fight
for their
foreign
[Music]